just not time for this expanding when
you see these brackets right I just try
and think of people coming to a house
and then saying hi
right when you when you come to my house
it's nice to say hi to everyone who's
there it's a bit sort of dog to like say
hi to one person and then just ignore
the rest of the people sure hey is
coming to these guys house okay so he
needs degree both of those AAA going
okay so it first see does 3a right hey a
times 3a what's that 8 times 3 is 24 8
times a we can write that as a square
nice okay good
you said hire the first guy now yes to
say hi to the next guy negative 7 so
negative 7 times 8 is 56 don't forget
the sign that goes with it okay yeah you
gotta watch that first signs all right
so one guy's gone to one house now we've
got another guy at different house okay
so he says hire the first guy for a next
one 4 times 5 is 20
okay now I've done my expansion then
they say expand and simplify so you have
a look and you see are there any like
terms and the answer is yes there are
some like terms
there's ease here and is ease here okay
now that is other 80 but this isn't a
square it's different isn't it right
different so yeah we leave him out the
front 20 40 squared what's this - 56 and
4 negative 52 plus 28 you finished